[Music]
movie magic is what transports us to
unique worlds and what brings magical
characters to life but have you ever
wondered what some iconic screen moments
would look like without their visual
effects in this video we'll be taking
you behind the scenes of some of the
most iconic moments from your favorite
movies and tv shows as much as we wish
it was possible we all know that humans
just can't fly and that the hulk just
doesn't exist so how exactly do they
make things like superheroes and
dinosaurs seem so real it all happens in
the editing room so let's take a look at
the behind the scenes of sets like
maleficent the hunger games and the
avengers before all the cgi gets added
in would you like to see
is it safe
from the monstrous waves to the debris
that line the water during battle
pirates of the caribbean is full of
dashes of cgi and vfx editing that bring
the movie to life but there's one
specific moment from the dead men tell
no tales that looks completely different
behind the scenes
the ghost shark scene featuring jack
sparrow and henry turner was filmed in
three different locations an actual
outdoor scenery a small water tank and
an indoor set that was completely blue
screen their rowboat was put on a gimbal
so that it would give the appearance
that they were actually being attacked
by sharks angelina jolie put her all
into the making of maleficent but no
matter how much of a renegade she was on
screen her character would not have come
to life without the help of cgi vfx and
a very interesting machine called a fork
tuner angelina was secured into a
machine that was controlled by other
people in order to get the motions right
they basically became puppets while
filming everything was completely blue
screen and her wings were added later on
in editing
the fairies in their small form were
also completely animated using a special
program the actress's faces were
processed so that they'd be able to copy
their exact animation later on it's
probably no surprise that the majority
of this film is cgi and visual effects
but what might surprise you is how baby
groot and rocket looked behind the
scenes they were well basically not
there both characters are completely cgi
[Music]
during filming they'd have stuffed
animals and models of stand-ins so the
actors wouldn't be completely lost
beauty and the beast is where most
millennials got their first taste of
love and romance but there's nothing
lovely and romantic about how beauty and
the beast looked behind the scenes dan
stevens didn't have a super realistic
beast costume instead he wore a motion
capture suit the costume helped the
editors use cgi to make the beast come
to life later on the br guest scene was
also pretty lackluster behind the scenes
lumiere's grand performance was later
added in during editing which left emma
watson acting at a fancy table alone
avatar took 10 years to make so you can
only imagine how much effort went into
making everything perfect pandora itself
was created completely using green
screen and vfx but what's even more
interesting is the way the avatars were
brought to life the actors wore motion
capture suits to film their scenes and
also had to get 3d models of themselves
done so they could digitally make their
avatar based on their appearance later
on looks like you
this is your avatar now jake
a whopping 300 shots were made using vfx
for divergent to produce the utopian
city we see in the film that includes
the dauntless train jumping scene that
catapults triss into the world of danger
it was actually filmed in six different
locations with a platform that was
completely made later with visual
effects what you see in the film is
actually the editing team blending clips
from different locations to seamlessly
fit together
is it just me
or are they trying to kill us
taylor lautner didn't get a special wolf
suit instead he explored the magical
qualities grey spandex had to offer and
acted out his scenes with kristen
stewart to make sure she got the eye
contact right then the vfx team did
their magic and created jacob's wolf
form later on they also used cgi to edit
actress mackenzie foy's face on
different age children after renesmee
was born let's just be grateful we
dodged them using chuck asme it was
nessie who wanted me there nessie you
nicknamed my daughter after the loch
ness monster grey's anatomy may not have
the need for fancy editing like cgi and
vfx but their special effects and prop
team have their work cut out for them
the show brings to life some pretty
realistic medical procedures what you're
actually seeing is the actors working on
a dummy full of animal intestines what
the hell is that thing oh that is a
kidney in a jar that's not a bear how
did you get that in narnia characters
like aslan were completely computer
generated the actors would have to act
out their scenes alone to make it a
little bit easier they would have
stand-ins where the character would be
for azlin they even came up with a type
of model that could be controlled by
someone inside that way they could get
some of his movements naturally
[Music]
girl on fire catching fire fire was a
huge part of the hunger games franchise
and the majority of the time it was
added into shots using cgi and vfx well
i was just
hoping that i wouldn't burn to death for
instance katniss's costumes both in the
first second and third films were all
thanks to the editing team and jennifer
lawrence actually filmed the scene where
katniss runs from the flames in the
arena completely without fire the dark
forest was huge in the wizard of oz
spin-off and it wouldn't have been able
to come alive without cgi
hate the dark forest hate the dark
forest during filming james franco
actually had to dodge poles meant to be
the tree branches of the forest that
were controlled by the crew the china
glass girl was also completely done in
the editing room for the space scenery
in the movie almost everything was shot
using a green screen the filmmakers also
had to find the perfect way to make it
seem like the actors were acting without
gravity
for the majority of the filming they
were strapped into a harness to give the
camera effect that they were floating in
space the red queen might not have
seemed as malicious and intimidating if
it wasn't for her disproportioned head
or if it wasn't helena bonham carter
i used to have the white cream now her
head is so small tiny it's a purple of a
head but her body proportions were only
altered in editing for filming she
looked completely normal there were also
a bunch of other iconic scenes that
looked interesting behind the scenes
welcome to jurassic world jurassic world
may have had its audiences believing
that dinosaurs might one day roam the
earth again but for a lot of the filming
no type of dinosaur fake or real was
even present instead the actors would
perform the scene while being mindful of
the markers that told them where the
dinosaurs were meant to be if the actor
had a scene where they were interacting
with the dinosaur they would have people
dress up in fake dinosaur heads and act
as a stand-in the most impressive part
of the avengers end game is probably how
well they made the hulk scenes come to
life mark ruffalo wore a special motion
suit and headpiece while acting so that
they'd later be able to transform him
and his facial features into the hero
put the brains and the bra together and
now look at me best of both worlds
another notable cgi moment is when they
had to actually use programs to create
captain marvel's hair the iconic moment
that black panther rose from the fire
and ashes to show everyone he was still
alive i am not dead
is probably something i and a lot of
other marvel fans will never forget but
behind the scenes all chadwick boseman
had to do was step onto some foam blocks
and the rest was all edited in the only
character in the jungle book who wasn't
the product of cgi or vfx was mowgli the
rest of his jungle friends were made
with cgi the actor had fake animals on
set to help him imagine the scene and
deliver his lines better the majority of
the jungle was also completely done
using cgi
relax kid no need to get worked up okay
daenerys flying her dragon is nothing
short of magical but behind the scenes
it was a little less graceful they had
amelia clark climb up on an animatronic
dragon surrounded by a green screen that
would mimic the movements of flying the
editor's job was to bring all of that to
life
sorry to say folks but gollum really
doesn't exist not even behind the scenes
unless you count his actor andy circus
dressed up in a motion suit saying
precious
but the credit all goes to the visual
effects team who brought the character
to life perfectly are we really
surprised that a portion of this film
was spent on a yacht all these scenes
were actually filmed in a studio with
green screens the iconic scene where the
yacht is taken over by some pretty
intense waves wouldn't have been
possible without cgi and visual effects
either
[Music]
so that's what pandora actually looks
like james cameron's avatar is one of
the most visually stunning films ever
made but what does it look like without
all the cgi the animators have taken
what the actors are doing and gone even
beyond that nati lives a pretty unique
lifestyle as one of the navi on the
planet of pandora one of the things that
we see nati partake in is drinking water
from a leaf but because director james
cameron loves to rely on technology
innovation the way that the scene was
actually filmed without cgi may surprise
you zoe saldana was required to work
with a gray plastic contraption to model
as the leaf while holding a water bottle
covered in duct tape to simulate water
coming from the tape we guess that's why
they call it movie magic it's the most
high-tech film in terms of its execution
you may or may not have had an awkward
kiss in your life but it probably wasn't
as awkward as it was for sam worthington
and zoe saldana when they had to kiss as
jake and nati while filming avatar while
in the movie itself with all the added
cgi the scene plays out romantically
without all the cgi worthington and
saldana had to kiss with their motion
captured jumpsuits and with green dots
all over their face so that the motion
capture on their character's cgi bodies
would be accurate and more real we
created a manually operated gimbal rig
that they could balance on one of the
most exciting action scenes in all of
avatar was definitely the flying banshee
obviously a lot of cgi was needed to be
done to bring the banshee to life as
there's no living real world counterpart
to the creature in order to capture jake
flying on the banshee sam worthington
was required to fly on the back of a
moving plastic structure where he'd be
flung around with wires all while
wearing the motion capture suit honestly
we think we'd just prefer the ride at
disney world that seems a bit more
comfortable
see them flying these things they're
working hard it's always intense
whenever anybody in a movie yells but
when a blue skinned alien like nathiri
yells it's even more powerful
you will never be one of the people
despite the goofy motion capture getup
and the silly plastic navi ears saldana
was still able to be quite intimidating
on set layers of additional cgi were
added in order to make nativi and the
rest of the na'vi look even more real in
the film you definitely wouldn't want to
take nati off
i at least have no idea that i'm wearing
this i feel like i'm blue and i'm nine
feet tall the big villain of avatar was
stephen lang's colonel miles quarwich
who unlike a lot of the other characters
who required cg is actually a human one
might assume that the colonel's mech
suit design was all cgi but they would
be wrong the main core design of the
suit was a practical effect but it was
the arm and the digital screens that
were later added with additional cgi
work in order to make the suit a more
formidable force to the navi the final
product proved to be quite the treat to
the navi and made lang's colonel an even
more memorable villain with rumors that
he'll be back for the sequel he may even
bring that neck suit back
oh yeah who's bad that's right
one of the first dangerous creatures
that jake encounters in the jungles of
pandora is the fierce thanator while the
thanator is quite intimidating on screen
the creature wasn't much to look at
before the cgi was added in fact before
the cgi was added standing in for the
thanator was a red tennis ball on a long
gray stick held by a crew member in
order for the actors to go on queue the
crew member holding the thanators stand
in would lunge at them life on pandora
would likely be much easier if all the
navi had to worry about was a tennis
ball on a stick cameron has a knack for
working with actors and actresses he's
worked with before so of course one of
the actresses he brought with him to
avatar was his alien star sigourney
weaver weaver plays grace in the film
and doesn't just play the character in
human form but also as a navi while even
in her navi form grace typically wears
human clothes behind the scenes weaver
had to still wear a motion capture suit
to convincingly play grace's navi avatar
from alien to ghostbusters sigourney
weaver has clearly made her mark in the
sci-fi genre we had horses galloping
around this place it wasn't just the
human actors who were behind motion
capture technology on the set of avatar
as actual horses were used under motion
capture technology for the dire horses
the horses were equipped with dots on
their body much like their human
co-stars in order for them to be
transformed later with visual effects
the horses were brought to the sound
stage of the film and cameron would film
the actors behind the navi riding the
horses with the special technology that
would allow him to be their cgi
counterparts as they were filming who
knows maybe those horses went on to take
other motion capture roles as well
despite all the extensive cgi and motion
capture present throughout avatar that
didn't mean the actors had to perform
less stunts in fact it was quite the
opposite whenever we saw the navi
climbing up the vines of the ominous
floating rocks on pandora cameron had
the actors behind the navi climb a
similar structure all in their motion
capture gear the final cgi was added
later but still that didn't make the
climb not dangerous though you can't
really become one of the navi without at
least getting a little bit rugged with
yourself and your environment motion
capture wasn't always available when
capturing scenes with the navi
especially when they shared the screen
with the human characters when recording
the scene where jake first wakes up in
his navi form cameron filmed the actors
playing the human doctors working around
an empty gurney behind the lens of
cameron's camera he was able to see the
cgi character we went to
kauai we went way up in the mountains
and we acted out the scenes before the
motion capture work was done for avatar
sam worthington and zoe saldana filmed
without their suits half naked in hawaii
this would be done in order so james
cameron could know how to plan all their
scenes that would need motion capture
such as the bow and arrow scene the tree
of voices is perhaps one of the most
gorgeous looking set pieces in all of
avatar but behind the scenes and without
the cgi that sacred tree wasn't much to
look at
in fact the trees were mainly just
pieces of rope that were used to
simulate the long leaves and branches of
the trees that netiri would present to
jake the final cgi would be added into
the production later to say these stunt
guys i mean they really just they gave
us their all the na'vi clearly have a
different culture than what we're used
to and cameron wanted to display some of
the tribal customs of the main tribe in
the film the group of four actors may
not have had the biggest roles in the
film but that didn't mean their work
wasn't difficult these actors ultimately
had to memorize a tribal dance of the
na'vi in all their motion capture suits
now that's true commitment to the craft
if this was cg i could have moved that
30 seconds so the whole time i was
shooting the virtual camera i was
complaining that it wasn't live action
well there were times on set where james
cameron and his crew had more accurate
models of the dragon assault ships there
were times where the models wouldn't be
enough in order to film the scene
cameron had the motion capture board use
a metal-like chair in the middle of the
set that would be moved around by crew
members a fan was also placed in front
of the actors in order to properly
capture the wind blowing in their
characters faces while the real set may
not have been as exciting as actually
flying on a ship as a navi on pandora
the cast and crew certainly made the
most of it they developed the most
lightweight 3d system possible so it's
very sophisticated technology the 3d
much like the cgi had to be recorded in
a distinct way using two cameras this
scene where the kernel is attacked on
his mech by one of the navi used two
cameras to perfect the 3d and the cgi
one camera would be used for the live
action elements and the other would be
used for the cg 3d elements i need you
to put up 10 million dollars to prove we
can make this movie far from home
wouldn't be the same movie without its
incredible special effects everything
from touching up spidey's suits to
creating the elementals required
multiple companies hundreds of people
and hours of work so we'll spend this
video breaking down their additions to
the film and just how incomplete it
would look without them in every
interview when i wear the bubble hat and
i'm like
no you didn't
far from home's most memorable scene has
got to be the intense illusion battle
the big midway fight sequence of the
film frame store the company in charge
of the sequence was given an unusual
amount of freedom to create the scene
they weren't given a set script to
follow instead they were given the
creative freedom to come up with the
concepts for the illusions at the same
time they were animating and adding
effects to the shots this gave them the
unique opportunity to provide direction
for the onset production team for
example with this shot where mj is
attacked by mysterio frame store blocked
out the animation ahead of time with a
cgmj complete with precise lighting from
the moon and lights of the eiffel tower
this rendered footage was passed along
to the set production who were able to
recreate the exact lighting frame store
needed for the shot this allowed them to
slip zendaya's performance into the
final product looking absolutely perfect
by the way the construction site where
the battle takes place
100
cg frame store created the entire
building model adding tom holland's
mocap footage on top they used a mocap
suit instead of filming tom in costume
to save time on set all of those reality
bending illusions would have meant way
too many costume changes for just one
sequence that nightmare inducing zombie
iron man utilized mocap as well frame
store went through several designs for
the undead hero finding the right
balance to be horrifying without showing
anything too gruesome the final product
finds a good middle ground resembling a
mummy beneath the broken bits of
machinery
marvel moviegoers are no stranger to the
incredible holograms of this cinematic
universe which means the vfx teams have
to keep their designs consistent with
the marvel style while putting in a few
new twists to keep the visuals from
getting stale for long time fans for
this scene where mysterio is introduced
as quentin beck and explains the
elemental attacks filming was done using
a special light box table rising sun
pictures had to not only design and
place the holograms in the scene but
adjust the lighting and colors depending
on which holograms were showing to make
them look like they were really in the
room with the actors the work had to be
done in layers sometimes completely
removing the lighting from on set
the lighting in the raw footage lacks
the subtle colors reflecting from the
holograms that don't just make the scene
look pretty but create an atmosphere to
complement the actors performances
sometimes an actor's job boils down to
fighting invisible monsters on set the
scene with the water elemental battle
was filmed on set with recreations of
buildings from venice on top of a huge
pool of water and blue screens as
backdrops while the scene utilized a ton
of cg most of the stunts were
accomplished by tom and his stunt
doubles luke scott and greg townley i
never have a stunt level it's always me
vfx not only hid the wires required to
help tom jump from pole to pole and volt
onto the rialto bridge but filled in the
backgrounds of venice and of course
brought the water elemental to life
there were no rigs or dummies used for
the monster which means the actors had
to rely on their imaginations to really
sell their performances all of that
water they were drenched with was real
though and very cold
similar techniques were used for filming
the scenes in london while portions of
the scenes set on tower bridge were
filmed on location they also filmed
using set pieces such as the tour bus in
front of green screens the shots
littered with rubble and broken down
cars were set pieces in front of green
screens too for wide shots imageworks
built a complete 3d model of tower
bridge this model was also used for
filming all the destruction that took
place during the climactic final battle
during all this action we see tons of
drones in various states of despair
imageworks was able to create all of
these broken bots by altering their
original models the drones were
constructed out of various individual
pieces all coming together to form a
single machine like the water elemental
the drones didn't use any objects on set
as stand-ins to help the actors
visualize the scene here's what peter's
final confrontation with beck really
looked like on set
believe it or not this scene set in a
vibrant field of tulips was filmed in an
empty grassland in the uk the jets and
all the flowers were cg image engine had
to simulate an entire field of tulips
with natural wind as well as the jet
landing over two million tulips were
simulated in this scene there were eight
colors and eight different tulips
created for each color
in order to render all of them
efficiently they used a method called
precaching where software will download
data ahead of time in anticipation of
its use that way the computers weren't
forced to simulate 2 million flowers at
the same time stripped of cgi this scene
is just tom holland and john favreau
standing in some grass
did you know imageworks did vfx for all
the previous spider-man movies that's
right they provided effects for the
original trilogy and the amazing
spider-man producers were actually
reluctant to go to them again for the
mcu installments since they wanted to
give the third iteration of the hero a
fresh new look that was until they saw
this test footage imageworks whipped up
to prove that they were up to the task
that's not tom holland in costume that's
completely cg the 3d model looked and
moved so convincingly that even tom
holland himself was fooled to innovate
on their previous work they focused on
making mcu's spider-man the most
realistic one yet they did this by
studying imperfections in tom's
movements from unused takes and
incorporating them into the animated
spider-man moments of hesitation or
getting caught off balance helped make
the cg spidey feel far more grounded in
reality than any of the previous films
while some of spidey's suits are
completely computer generated and
require a mocap suit even the costumes
on set require digital tweaking here and
there it can be as simple as removing
wrinkles to keep the suit looking smooth
or adding wear and tear from the intense
action sequences
following in tony stark's footsteps
peter enters the workshop in the back of
the jet to build his own suit for the
first time since he ran around queens in
sweats while the shots of peter entering
are all cg there was also a physical set
for the workshop after filming tom on
set the holograms were added in post
with vfx image engine had to create an
exact replica of the set in order to
accurately layer the holograms and
moving machinery over the real footage
bringing the workshop to life in the
final product this scene isn't just an
important character moment for peter but
a chance for the audience to see what
goes into building a stark tech spidey
suit image engine had to decide what the
individual elements of the suit would
look like ultimately breaking it down
into three layers for the construction
process
there is a white wet fiber layer a layer
of black and red fabric detailing and a
layer for hard surfaces such as the
eyepieces and chest patches the company
in charge of vfx for the final battle in
london imageworks kept these details
consistent when adding battle damage to
the suit if we look at his suit closely
during his emotional reunion with mj we
can see patches of white material where
the suit sustained damage from epic
battle scenes impenetrable costumes and
impossible stunts marvel constantly has
their fans jaws dropping with 98 of the
footage from the mcu films being sent to
the special effects editing
professionals it isn't hard to imagine
how different our favorite avengers look
behind the scenes but imagining and
seeing are two different things from
endgame to wandavision and peter parker
in between you won't believe how
dramatically different these marvel
scenes look without the power of vfx and
cgi
just a
big chocolate missile how iconic was
this girl power moment in avengers end
game however while it may have come
together seamlessly on screen the
arrival of the female avengers took a
bit more extra work behind the scenes as
you can see here each avenger had to be
added in almost one by one some of them
were included using special effects and
others just popped up from underneath
the camera's view
you got something for me
captain america's encounter with himself
while searching for the infinity stones
was already mind-boggling but watching
how they filmed the scene hurt our
brains even more chris evans filmed both
parts individually with his stunt double
swapping roles between takes the editors
did their magic later on to make it seem
as if it truly was a double trouble
situation
i can do this all day yeah i know
although heartbreaking watching tony
stark's sacrifice again is worth it just
to see how it looked behind the scenes
there was actually no infinity glove no
battle raging around him and no thanos
looming over him just rdj's pure talent
this vision vs vision fight in
wandavision took a lot of work paul
bettany filmed this scene with his stunt
double and they later digitally enhanced
his stunt doubles face to look like paul
instead you can also see that the upper
part of vision's suit as well as the
environment around them was added in
later with special effects
but i'm not the true vision
getting to see the true strength of
wanda's powers in one division was epic
but the cast and crew weren't treated to
the same experience while elizabeth
olsen was filming without special
effects wanda's combustion in the west
view town square kinda looked a little
like an adult temper tantrum but it's
still impressive to think about how it
all came together in the end
[Music]
this scene had our heart rates spiking
but we're glad to know tom holland
wasn't in any danger filming it behind
the scenes thanos ship was actually just
a green screen wall that tom holland was
climbing while attached to a wire and
wearing a motion capture suit we're too
high up you're running out of air
that makes sense
the final battle was much less
anticlimactic behind the scenes than on
screen the majority of the time the cast
wasn't even on set with one another at
the same time the day where the avengers
charged was when they had the most
people on set and even that pales in
comparison to all the digital enemies we
saw in the final cut if you look closely
you'll see the avenger army charged into
a green screen
filming black widow and her motorcycle
was an event that included a harley bike
specifically created for the film stunt
doubles and motorcycle cameras for
close-up shots they would film scarlett
johansson at a standstill but for action
shots they had her stunt double weaving
in and out of cars while two cameras
followed in front and behind on
motorcycles of their own
i'm always picking up after you boys
not all special effects are done with
vfx especially in the first episodes of
wandavision they swapped out wanda's red
waves of power for strings poles and
simple speed adjustments to achieve that
perfect 1950s style
well please eat before it gets cold
sorry to disappoint but thanos not real
not even behind the scenes in order to
bring him to life josh brolin had to
wear a big motion capture suit which
made his battle for the infinity
gauntlet with captain america in end
game a little awkward without all of the
special effects
captain america's shield was also added
with vfx meaning while filming it was
basically chris evans throwing an
imaginary weapon at josh brolin while he
pretended to get hit all six stones i
could simply snap my fingers
living on a land full of vibranium would
be epic but unfortunately wakanda was
all green screen and special effects
including their futuristic planes
however they still tried to make filming
as realistic as possible like the fight
scene between t'challa and umbaku where
the set designer created a pretty
realistic base for the shoot
glory to hanuman
dr strange's cape for a lot of the
scenes wasn't actually there benedict
cumberbatch would go through the motions
of grabbing and putting on the cape but
it was added in later on using special
effects they just couldn't recreate how
life-like it was without help from the
digital realm however in other scenes
where it wasn't the main focus it was
just a part of benedict's costume
mark ruffalo has expressed in the past
how embarrassing it sometimes was to be
dressed in a large motion capture suit
around the rest of the avengers cast
while we admit it looks a bit odd it was
also that the editing team could do
their magic like in this scene with the
hulk and the ancient one he's wearing
his suit but also standing on an
elevated surface in a green screen
studio instead of new york
and hulk
smash
it's obvious to see that the spider-man
illusion battle was completely done
using digital effects thanks to the
company frame store however how did they
get spider-man to move so much like tom
holland well they made sure that they
filmed the stunts and movements with tom
in a motion capture suit so that they'd
be able to add the extra realism to the
scene zendaya's part was also added into
the digital sequence later on
we saw plenty of different versions of
vision in wandavision however what we
didn't realize is that for a portion of
the series he was actually blue avatar
blue the showrunners worked with the
makeup department to find what color
paint would look the best translated in
black and white turns out blue looked
much better than maroon and they stuck
with the color through every black and
white scene he shot
humans are odd
valkyrie's entrance was intense but when
you take a peek behind the curtains the
intensity is deflated the horse she was
riding was actually just an animatronic
and the area around her was completely
green screen even wanda's magical drop
down was done with just elizabeth olsen
and a harness
as much as we wish these portals were
real those magic rings we see in doctor
strange are actually just shiny metal
circles with a green screen backdrop
they were elevated to give the effects
of the actors stepping in and did help
them meet their marks evidently adding a
little more realism to it all
hi everyone i hope you're enjoying this
film to get captain marvel in the air
involved a lot of vfx green screen and
major dedication from brie larson the
actress was attached to a contraption
made of poles that allowed the film crew
to rotate her and manipulate her in any
direction they needed this was all done
in front of a green screen so that her
powers location and even part of her
suit could be added in during
post-production it takes a lot to make a
superhero look fabulous
the spider-man cast didn't actually film
in london at least for this battle scene
and far from home the vfx team created a
digital london for the film while the
actors performed in a studio with
minimal props and structures compared to
what we see in the final cut
sorry to break the illusion but iron
man's suit wasn't actually physically
there the majority of the time
oftentimes rdj would just wear part of
the armor on top of a motion capture
suit there were other scenes where he
would wear a physically larger suit with
his helmet being the only part added
with vfx it really depended on what the
script required of him that day
is everything a joke to you funny things
the marvel creators got to spend extra
time playing around with falcon for his
new series falcon and the winter soldier
and we aren't complaining they put in
the work researching and using footage
from skydivers in order to get the
perfect look for the falcons flying
scenes they seamlessly fit together raw
shots and digital creations to give us
these shots
getting chris evans to look a lot
smaller than he really was was a
challenge
the production team had to go through
multiple steps first the scene was
filmed with body double leander dini who
still had to diet for the role they then
digitally replaced his face with chris
evans in editing sometimes they would
even have to scale down the actor
compared to the environment depending on
the scene iron man wasn't the only one
with cool gadgets at his expense we got
to see happy's plane in spider-man far
from home and we were just as impressed
as peter parker however behind the
scenes the plane didn't really exist
while they did build part of the
interior as a set the majority was
created digitally
watching how they filmed the rocket
raccoon scenes is kind of unsettling
take a look rocket was of course created
digitally but in order to capture
realistic movements sean gunn the
director's brother acted out the scenes
in a motion capture suit because of the
animal-like movements he was able to
replicate
the vulture wasn't slick and fast which
means the spider-man filmmakers needed
to make sure the vulture's special
effects portrayed his heaviness it
required some research on how humans
look flying with jet packs so that they
could replicate it and then add in those
digitally created wings
the streets of free city are very much a
world that feel a little bit like our
own but way better
what movie magic transformed ryan
reynolds into dude free city is more
like cgi city nothing in this world is
possible without some incredible vfx
ryan reynolds in this new improved body
originally dude was meant to look
exactly like guy with ryan reynolds
pulling double duty as both characters
but instead of taking the time to shoot
ryan acting twice and buff him up later
in post-production the crew decided to
find a very beefy actor who could
portray him instead aaron reed was the
chosen one not true i gained 312 pounds
for this film reed was shot using motion
capture notice all those dots on his
face and in post-production lola vfx
stitched reynold's face onto reed's body
like a real-life frankenstein situation
he's spectacular
for the fight with dude the team used
wires props and mats to get the action
just right the scene definitely took
some great fight choreography and an
amazing stunt team to pull it off
also many of the iconic props like the
captain america shield were filmed with
plain looking stand-in props and then
updated later with cgi
lots of stunt performers and vfx were
involved with the fight scene that
happened when guy and molotov girl head
to the stash house to retrieve her
stolen code the scene involved spawn
points tons of weapons and video game
fighting styles behind the scenes people
were being thrown onto mats while
attached to wires and performers were
pretending to be hit by numerous
projectiles and weapons to get the
motorcycle slide just right guy's bike
was pulled forward with wires and ryan
reynolds stunt double stepped in to do
most of the dangerous stuff it all comes
together to create a perfectly chaotic
scene where players appear out of
nowhere for an all-out brawl and
honestly it looks like a pretty fun
albeit exhausting day to have been on
set was that cool it felt really cool a
lot of the movie's most dangerous scenes
were done as practical stunts with cgi
added later for the complicated
construction site chase it took a lot of
planning trained stunt performers and
vfx to get things right many of these
injuries like guys head becoming a
little too friendly with a concrete
pillar are only possible in a video game
and would surely send you to the
hospital or worse in real life to create
this scene of guy falling and landing in
the bubble suit the filmmakers used a
stunt performer on wires positioned
against a green screen for close shots
and a digi-double version of ryan
reynolds for the wide shots and extreme
bounces once on the ground ryan was
really filmed in a prop bubble which was
either really comfortable or really
uncomfortable we're not sure but
someone's gotta ask him
and that was the heartbreaking story of
blue shirt guy real cars were used on
the streets of free city but they had a
cgi layover put on top of them to make
them look more unique video game worthy
and futuristic the movie director sean
levy said we want the world of our city
filled with vehicles that aren't just
everyday we want them in models and
customized editions and colors that are
all kind of like dialed up reality with
the cgi layover they could smooth and
round out the car's edges add signs of
damage you name it all without actually
damaging or changing the cars the
vehicles ended up looking a little
unlike models we have in real life but
close enough to be recognizable in the
real world and cool enough to be coveted
by video game enthusiasts
impressive adding all the chaos that
surrounds the cars during epic chase
scenes was also incredibly important to
get the free city world to really feel
like a grand theft auto inspired
universe where there's all kinds of
pandemonium pyrotechnics sparks and
mayhem were added to these scenes while
the stunt drivers cruised the streets so
they didn't have to deal with any real
obstacles you can see in this scene that
some cars they hit aren't really there
at all including this massive pileup the
chase scenes got the action right by
filming stunt drivers in front of green
screens they were filmed with a robotic
motion controlled camera moving on a
track to keep things smooth like when
channing tatum's character does a
slow-mo 360.
you're so hot
oh i know
free guy was shot in boston with a few
reshoots taking place in la while the
interiors were built on airport hangars
or sound stages but other cities like
seoul tokyo seattle pittsburgh and even
christopher nolan's gotham city served
as inspiration for how the video game
world would look to get everything right
the team actually created free city
twice first as live-action footage with
digital editions and again as a fully cg
environment they created futuristic
unique and dilapidated storefronts by
using real buildings and overlaying them
with cgi to turn them into the unique
free city shops that we see on our
screens production designer ethan tobin
said that they did a ton of branding and
developed two stories of entire blocks
with signage that you'd never see in the
real world different cameras were used
to distinguish between free city and the
real world the video game scenes were
shot with a large format camera and
spherical lenses with a color palette
that was almost animated while the real
life scenes were filmed in a more
down-to-earth style with a more
restricted color palette
you're real and i'm what i'm what
you're not
when the glasses go on the world becomes
even more different it's like the truman
show where the main character doesn't
know what's really going on until he's
given away to see it so there had to be
a pretty big distinction between guy's
reality and the player's reality to
accomplish this there's another layer of
vfx creating what the game's players see
with director sean levy taking advantage
of the fact that he was the creator of
that world within the world these images
that appear all around free city for
players are meant to look even more
animated and interactive than the
fantasy city does to its npcs the team
also used different camera techniques
when guy puts on his glasses like having
it suddenly become first person and then
filming from behind him as if a video
game player is actually changing their
camera perspective
that's not good
the street squeeze scene looks like it
could be right out of a superhero movie
which isn't so surprising considering
the film's vfx supervisor sven gilberg
also worked on avengers infinity war and
end game in this scene there were some
real cards being driven by trained
professionals but for the most part all
the action was compiled together with
some incredible vfx these shots on the
streets closing in the streets crumbling
and cars being flung every which way
were all added by the incredibly
talented people at scanline vfx so don't
worry no stunt drivers were harmed in
the making of this scene the destruction
of free city was also a complicated
scene literally the world can reshape it
required incredible vfx but it also
required the actors to pretend that it
was really being destroyed because in
reality all of that destruction was
accomplished with some epic cgi that had
the city pixelating into a million
pieces scanline vfx was responsible for
the scene which had the world of free
city literally falling out from
underneath its citizen's feet for the
stampede in the city there were some
real actors involved running for their
lives but there were also extra digital
renderings of characters added in later
to fill out the crowd as for guy finally
reaching the life itself island you
guessed it the green oasis was entirely
animated this
is free city and the people who wear
sunglasses are heroes computer animation
was also used to create these iconic
scenes where players free-fall and then
glide into free city the scenes
introduce us to what's really possible
in the video game world some of the
characters like this guy coming in like
a flying squirrel are entirely animated
but when characters are shown coming
down in parachutes or getting close to
the ground they're really attached to
wires on a crane the crew had quite the
complicated setup prepared to get all
these falling and flying scenes just
right
behind the cgi of venom there are stunts
practical effects and a ton of
impressive acting
venom is a really visually exciting
movie to watch especially because of the
wild and shocking transformation we see
eddie undergo the complex villain is
brought to life thanks to some truly
remarkable cgi
behind the scenes is just as
action-packed as the final cut of these
films
venom 2 definitely doesn't hold back on
the wild action and impressive cgi work
these tendrils have a total life of
their own in this shot but behind the
scenes the carnage arm grab looks pretty
different instead of real tendrils wires
and harnesses did the heavy lifting to
make sure the cameras captured what they
needed
the restricted spin around while being
held by wires looks far from comfortable
to deal with but it was well worth it
considering just how epic the final
result looks
while tom hardy gives a great
performance the shape-shifting
transformation we see on screen from man
to super villain is all thanks to
painstakingly detailed cgi work the vfx
team actually created animations for
every single frame we see
while it took a lot of time and
expertise it was the best way to make
sure the transformation looked as slick
and real as it does every layer of the
detailed animation images contributes to
making venom's interactions with people
and the world looks so convincing
one of the coolest scenes in the first
venom takes to the streets with this
massive mess of black tendrils moving
from flat on the ground to a powerful
stance
while his movements look flawless in the
final cut behind the scenes was a very
different story as the actors were hard
at work to perfect choreography to
properly map out the movements the cgi
team needed the best footage to work
with to bring venom to the screen in
such a central and powerful way
in the end they definitely were not
disappointed
the second venom film features a pretty
massive leap onto the hood of a car
that's made to look like an effortless
motion in post-production but as we can
see behind the scenes a lot of prep had
to be done and safety measures had to be
considered for this superhuman moment
seeing just how intense the stunt is
without cgi is a great example of how
much acting the performers need to do to
appear as though these daunting tasks
are totally effortless
venom let there be carnage is filled
with plenty of shooting scenes which of
course are no match for the creature the
drama of it all is still as present
without cgi considering the high stakes
and loud noises
all the flashes of light and details to
support the storytelling are courtesy of
added effects since they were just
shooting blanks on the set
the living room sequence in the first
venom film is one of the most intense
battles in part because of the power
imbalance one versus three hardly seems
fair except for when the one actually
turns out to be pretty fine on his own
thanks to the power of venom the cgi in
this scene is key for showing the
surprising and powerful transformation
tom hardy goes through a whole lot of
stage combat and practical effects
contributed to executing the battle so
well
as he slowly discovers the sheer amount
of power he has tom hardy looks a bit
crazy staring down at his fist as if it
were a monster and to be fair with the
cgi monstrous is a pretty good
descriptor for what we end up seeing
part of what makes the cgi so effective
is the fact that hardy performed each of
these scenes with 100 commitment
especially when he was embodying venom
the motorcycle chase scene is one of the
most complicated sequences shot for the
first film and an epic point of action
while the scene itself only lasts a few
minutes before filming even commenced
planning happened for months to make
sure it could all be carried out
efficiently while making sure the epic
footage was still captured what's even
crazier is that the whole chase was
actually filmed and cgi was what managed
to weave the whole scene together
seamlessly and with impressive detail no
less
stunt doubles took over for the actual
riding on the streets robbie madison and
joe dryden performed legendary motorbike
stunts considering all the planning it's
no surprise about 40 cars ended up being
used and inevitably destroyed over the
course of filming while cgi did amp up
the look of this nosedive through flames
stunt performer dryden really did whip
through fire to make sure the team had
the best shot they could get to be
perfected of course with special effects
we get to see the venom tendrils in full
force when they bring hardy's character
to safety well as safe as someone can be
whipping through the city on a
motorcycle
filming in studios saw the actor
maneuvered by a harness to move from
floating in the air to regaining control
but the moment cgi came into play was
when the scene really came to life
robbie madison looked danger straight in
the face when he was preparing for the
huge jump on the famously steep bullet
hill this was actually the performer's
very first jump in america and was it
ever a cool one since the team was
limited in how many times the stunt
could be performed they needed cgi to
make sure the scene looked good in the
movie after three stunt jumps madison
was able to really hear the sounds of
the cars crashing in the intensity of
the whole experience hit him the effects
added in post made the jump look even
more legendary
for the wicked motorcycle sandwich the
performers were in real cars and hardy
was actually on top of a motorcycle but
the whole scene was filmed while the
vehicles were stationary filming with a
blue screen behind them hardy had some
good opportunities to really perform
well on the motorbike and all the while
not having to worry about his own safety
the cgi fills in the blank adding the
scenery and effects to amplify the
intensity of this moment
this motorcycle slide is nothing short
of impressive the two weeks spent to
create a specially designed metal plate
for the motorcycle to attach to in order
to safely whip around with such speed
was well worth the effort the experience
of filming was pretty wild and the final
result adds a really cool unexpected
moment to the whole sequence
the visual details of venom really
complete the masterpiece
this apartment fight was pretty wicked
and included the vicious weight throwing
move
luckily the actors weren't in any actual
dangers since there weren't any real
weights on the set cgi isn't just used
for big explosions and out of this world
creatures sometimes generating images
for more typical or practical effects is
what's needed
with major throws come a whole lot of
wires and harnesses
while in the first movie we see exactly
what outer force throws him around
behind the scenes it almost looks a bit
more like magic since hardy was hooked
up to wires and harnesses making sure
the tricky stunts could be filmed safely
it looks incredible in rehearsal so it's
no surprise that the final product is a
gem as well
slamming into the wall over and over
again can't have been the most
comfortable experience for the actor
though
there were a fair number of window jumps
in the first venom film some simple
leaps from inside a corridor shattering
glass in the midst and in other cases
epic leaps through the air in both cases
cgi played a key role filling in the
scenery and making performers look like
they're really soaring especially when
it came to all the venom detailing
thor might be the god of thunder but the
real gods when it came to this
production were the gods of cgi we've
got 20 thor scenes without cgi coming at
ya that include everything from a mocap
suited up hella to chris hemsworth
hanging upside down by chains wait what
yeah you heard right let's go if anyone
knows how to land it's thor
nice work buddy and just in case you
doubted his power the epic hammer does
the trick is it just us or is hemsworth
exuding pure glory
good for you god of thunder
need to look extra cool get you some
fans and voila superhero style
could there be a more boss way to enter
a scene okay so it looks weird at first
but that's what cgi is for
kate blanchett creeps in front of the
blue screen until bam cool green portal
appears blanchett did have a real hammer
and toe on set but for the most part
what we see was thanks to the techies
the grand master knows how to make a
grand entrance
at least with the help of a mechanized
platform and some of the strongest crew
members we've ever seen seriously a
round of applause for the platform guys
gotta give it to the master too he moves
very smoothly for a 14 million year old
let's stop there what's he the god of
that's right thor's competition doesn't
look nearly as intimidating without the
special effects
cue awkward looking motion capture
bodysuits just because they looked silly
doesn't mean they were going to go easy
on thor though the grim mountain-filled
background is far from the elaborate
blue screen filled studio they actually
shot in but hey does the trick can you
say quick change making that swap happen
quickly and on cue with hemsworth's
command was all thanks to some image
layering by the vfx team sure the actors
had to film the scene twice in different
clothing but surely that was a heck of a
lot easier than actually figuring out
how to magically change the snap of
thor's fingers
a dash of landscape a sprinkle of
special lighting and
voila
every good god knows no throne room is
complete without a throne even before
cgi who needs the whole room once you've
got the elaborate throne anyway blue
screens and ramps pretty much do the
same thing until the time when vfx can
take over and dazzle probably the best
part about this cgi magic is the fact
that no one had to sweep that enormously
long hallway
you're in my seat
let's get one thing straight kate
blanchett knows how to work an amazing
cgi transformation running your fingers
through your hair is pretty special when
you're an asgardian goddess of death
nail
need some weapons and a full costume
real quick we can do you one better
blue screens
blanchett really brings it in this
electrifying scene okay well really it's
all the cgi team but still
she gives off the right vibe from the
land to the flurries of wind and the
electric current that lights up our
screens a masterful exhibition of both
the vfx team's skills and teles
two brothers both of them gods and
neither afraid to smack down yeah
they've got a complicated relationship
but they make a solid team hemsworth and
hiddleston's chemistry just makes it
even better
oh and all those cg backgrounds and
special effects to really convince us of
their godliness
um valkyrie you're supposed to stay
inside the ship tessa thompson is
clearly jacked that tight grip both on
the outside of the ship and when she's
at the wheel work thor has got some
pretty solid company when valkyrie is
around
at first glance it seems like there
wouldn't be too much cgi done for this
shot hemsworth is in a real environment
and in the grass but the transformation
between what was filmed and what we got
in the movie is stark
the most shocking of all
the grass unfortunately natural grass
wasn't quite up to snuff
only the bit in front of hemsworth
stayed and even still
it was enhanced
watch out valkyrie coming in hot the
suit is great but what really does it
for us is the flowing blue cape
tessa thompson's ninja skills are on
point as she fights flies and performs
valkyrie with undeniable enthusiasm and
fire this scene was in reality a lot
less intimidating for the warriors who
instead of battle armor were kitted out
in those cute motion capture suits and
valiantly heading towards a very safe
looking blue screen instead of the chaos
we actually get in the movie these
incredibly detailed special effects help
these actors look as epic as possible
we've got regular thor fat thor and
digital thor
yes you heard that correctly the stellar
cgi team rendered a fully digital double
of hemsworth as thor that could be used
to fine-tune the details when blended
with other special effects
but it was still all about hemsworth yep
the actor was being
tracked the whole time to use as a base
plus they wanted to capture all they
could of that pretty face so that when
combined with the digital thor we got
the best thor
the power forces between these
characters is a bit insane but on the
set the whole situation looks much less
effective
blanchett rocks the scene sporting an
always funny looking mocap suit managing
to perform as if she were kitted out to
the nines in hela's power suit not to
mention
the headdress
unfortunately this piece only came to
life in the computer generated world
although blanchett probably didn't mind
because honestly it doesn't look like it
would be the most comfortable or
practical piece to wear to be honest i
expected more need to smoothly glide
backwards chris hemsworth might be
offering a master class soon hemsworth
just got hooked up to wires while the
crew went at it with the giant rig
controlling the thor actor's movements
and it looks like it was quite the heavy
rig to control
when was the last time you were in a 160
000 person stadium never
same for the actors in this scene
because guess what
they're all made by computers
look how un-thor like hemsworth looks
fighting a hulk that isn't even there
those punches just don't land sorry
chris
parts of his arms and torso weren't
quite good enough so cgi leveled up when
hemsworth couldn't get help
no come on you love it i hate it
elevators were boring until now
this do-over hurst like mad to nail this
sequence and thanks to some cgi magic
they all pulled it off it was a bad day
to go against these brothers
classic thor hammer time and boy does
thor make it work he didn't always have
a real hammer but hemsworth knows the
power of the hammer and that was good
enough for the cameras until cgi could
jazz everything up
thor's got himself in a pickle hasn't he
gotta give it to hemsworth though he
managed to get all his dialogue out with
blood rushing to his head sorcher had it
pretty easy when the actual filming
happened waiting until the editing phase
to hop into that frame
so many people to reign over asgard so
little time there was odin loki and then
of course everything that went down
during ragnarok
asgard was actually a pretty even combo
of real outdoor spaces and blue screen
filled studios but at the end of the day
we know somebody better be bleeding
broken or on fire when the scarlet witch
was on set the fire was always brought
elizabeth olsen was constantly hooked up
to harnesses rigged to wire tracks and
suspended an air to portray all her
wanda magic and sometimes with very
little to work with visually we've got
16 of her most impressive scenes without
cgi coming right up now i think we're
just so excited
number one
seeing red nah that's just chaos magic
from the scarlet witch herself filming
the actress we get christmas-themed
colors but nothing about her performance
feels jolly olson brings the fire while
the effects team brought the visual fire
that's just very cool and it's very
satisfying number two
wanda's powers were totally
underestimated this woman's pain built
the entire city of westview a barren
construction lot is all you need when
the special effects and acting
performances are this good the 360
camera track that was set up around
olson to capture all the magic only
needed a touch of green screen to bring
the whole image to life in such a
stylistic way the cg team went the extra
mile so convincingly constructing
wanda's world with the old-fashioned
television visuals and all
number three
there was no doubt something strange
happening in the town of westview this
is for us so let me
handle it reaching her breaking point
for all to see brought an incredibly
powerful performance from elizabeth
olsen and very sophisticated special
effects to show just how powerful her
emotions and chaos magic were
number four
who knew which versus which could be so
intense
[Laughter]
catherine hahn and elizabeth olsen were
defying gravity literally hanging
opposite each other on a giant spinning
rig in a set that looked more like a
construction site than a place where a
tv show was being made their major
battle took place entirely in the air
with both actors hooked up to wires and
wire tracks that allowed them to zoom
through the air smoothly
number five
her first full marvel movie
she was gonna leave an impression make
no mistake see pictures of scarlet witch
and she's always like that when
elizabeth olson took to the screen we
got a full blast of power one of our
first glimpses of just how strong she
was came when she worked to clear
sokovia pushing through to exert all
those powers which honestly without the
cg does kind of look hilarious but her
hand movements and choreography are
still on point and exhibit all the grace
we know she has who else can cause such
damage with such elegance
number six
and she made him feel so real layers on
layers on layers of light ray visuals
came together to create the single
powerful image as we see the vision we
all want to see come to life
we'd never have guessed that in reality
the room was pretty empty save for those
green screens three-dimensional models
were rendered of each actor to bring
this unique transformation
wanda's powers are really all out for
this one and who can blame her the
scarlet witch was ready to be seen
number seven
the power hands choreo just keeps coming
almost anyone else would look ridiculous
doing these intricate and delicate moves
but olson pulls it off like a natural
that's what makes her unique no question
she's the perfect scarlet witch it's not
just shooting energy towards robots
there's some things that haven't that
aren't just about like being harmful her
powers really can do it all defending
and battling sure but her ability to
move objects and help her cohorts out
when they need it makes her that much
more powerful who else could give the
cap such a solid boost
number eight
is this the most boss lineup we've ever
seen we're marveling hard at these
female avengers strutting on a set that
honestly is pretty amazing as is
sure they weren't all actually in the
room together filming at exactly the
same time but we get the point it works
everyone just kind of taking their turns
moving around trying to help each other
out the cg team's job was much easier
working with this as a base as well
everything had a way of coming together
pretty seamlessly
number nine
having to go through it again and again
that's gotta hurt
just as quickly as he came back into her
life he was gone and in an incredible
visual display thanks to the cg team
what started as a green screen became a
multi-layered image to bring both
realistic backdrops and the extra magic
on top it was painful to watch but that
light brings the beauty
again
how long do we think these two were
standing together in such stillness for
this painful moment to be captured
number 10
no one was going to keep her away from
vision when she wanted in wanda got in
no need for huge displays of power a
simple hand gesture and some red cgi
light added to the picture are all you
need when you're the scarlet witch
window busting piece of cake render some
shattering glass visuals and we're all
set
number 11
wanda's powers came with the help of a
whole lot of crew members since the
style they were looking for was a pretty
specific kind of movement that's a
surprisingly hard thing to do in cg
puppeteering for real was the way to go
meanwhile special effects could help
hide all those real wires it was pretty
hard to ignore for the actors since they
had crew members getting right up close
and personal with them and the floating
props items were hooked up to the floor
hanging from the ceiling across rooms
whatever they needed they rigged it and
to add a bit of extra pizzazz the cg
team would sprinkle in some janky moving
items to blend in with the image
number 12.
wanda wasn't about to waste any time
getting back to work she already had
that fantastic scarlet witch suit on so
why let it go to waste green screen boss
outfit the signature glowing red cgi
perfect setting for reading the dark
hold and planning her next steps now
that she'd embraced all that chaos magic
power the possibilities are endless
props to olson for holding that
cross-legged position while rigged to
those wires for so long
number 13
when they want to stop the train better
stop or else they'll make it
luckily the train they were stopping was
already stopped and still on set making
the job a whole lot easier for them but
a bit harder for the cg team to make it
look active mix in those powers from the
power sibling duo and they were set blue
and red lights have never been more
powerful
number 14
crew assembled the airport fight is on
even with the tech and green screens
around it looks like this was an epic
day on set
that many stars running together that
much power that much talent that's
enough on its own plus they all really
bring the heat on this one olsen was
ready to fight we'd want her as a
teammate any day
number 15
in coming it's a wanda flying in olson
got used to being in a harness for
filming the better half of the last few
episodes of the series she was swooping
in with all the grace in the world toss
in the jazzy red glow hands to spice the
picture up and we're in business even
when she's wearing sweats
number 16
it's a whole new world live in color
four different colored versions of the
images were combined to create that
tv-like texture the twinkle effect nod
to that era of shows made for a perfect
detail thank you cg team oh not to
mention that extra upgrade that came
along slick and convenient assembling of
furniture
when elizabeth olsen is around
you know a scene is going to be good
when the cg team is on the job you know
the scene is going to be great
here we are behind the scenes
with loki there's no denying the
magnetic appeal of loki tom hiddleston's
incredible performance gets most of the
credit but even he needs help bringing
the trickster god to life on film to
celebrate loki getting his very own
series we're giving you a look at some
behind the scenes magic of how marvel
brings the god of mischief to the screen
in all his glory loki is still working
on that i think
for this scene from thor the dark world
the first thing they filmed was tom
hiddleston doing an impression of
captain america as loki complete with
cap's costume there wasn't a technical
reason for this apparently tom just
really wanted to wear the costume it's
not going to be you though we're going
to get chris to shoot it when he's on
set and we're going to he said none of
that this is my one chance to wear
captain america's suits later evans was
shown the footage and did his best to
mimic tom's performance replacing it in
the final product he it's him doing an
impression of me doing an impression of
him
and it's brilliant
a good villain needs a grand entrance
and loki certainly doesn't disappoint
loki's entrance in the first avengers
movie is a memorable one thanks in no
small part to the vfx team even without
the final polish and the wires still in
sight this shot of tom performing this
stunt is just as impressive as the
finished shot from the movie where loki
leaps through the air and takes down a
shield agent always
try and enjoy myself to be having the
best time
speaking of dramatic entrances this
scene from the first episode of loki
where he's being processed by the tva
was achieved with a real trapdoor and
tom hiddleston on wires he was hooked up
to a rig to achieve a controlled drop
ensuring his safety as they filmed the
stunt luckily tom already has a lot of
experience doing wire work since loki
always seems to be getting tossed around
just me
jumping into
trenches in the set
creating that iconic scene where loki
gets hulk smashed was tricky you can't
exactly do that with stunt work to pull
this off tom had a wire attached to his
ankle with a mat on the floor to catch
him
and three of the strongest stunt guys
holding the wire at the other end they
waited to interrupt his villainous
monologue and yanked hard pulling tom
out of frame and down onto the mat the
rest was done with hard work from the
special effects department the
experience of being yanked out of frame
was one i will not forget in hurry loki
and thor's banter in this scene from
thor the dark world where they break out
of asgard is unforgettable as well as a
brilliant mix of practical and special
effects chris and tom filmed this scene
on a set of the ship's interior with
special effects creating the holographic
interfaces and adjusting the lighting
accordingly while thor practically
throws loki out the door chris gives tom
a light shove who then has to throw
himself out of the door onto a mat below
i mentioned i love my scenes with chris
in every film there's a two-hander where
we kind of touch on this odin's
emotional departure in thor ragnarok
took place on a beautiful scenic
cliffside that doesn't actually exist
these scenes were filmed in a grassy
field with the future locations of new
asgard being entirely built around them
using cgi another surprising use of
digital effects in this scene is odin's
eye patch which was changed in post from
the plain black eye patch anthony
hopkins wore while filming yeah that
easy
well it's a trick dramatic entrances
probably run in the family because as
soon as hella arrives on the scene you
know she means business thor and loki
immediately know she's going to be
trouble and suit up to get this magical
costume change chris and tom were filmed
entering in both costumes the footage
was spliced together and the effects
team created thor's lightning and loki's
signature green shimmer of magic to
create a transition between these
changes putting them together for one
seamless shot look he was a bad guy
well look he was a misunderstood guy we
love seeing the odin sons work together
like when they teamed up in the dark
world using loki's illusion magic they
fooled malekith into believing loki had
betrayed thor going as far as pretending
to cut off thor's hand and give up jane
foster it's very accurate in this shot
loki literally kicks thor while he's
down sending him rolling on set it was
hiddleston delivering a kick that didn't
connect and hemsworth was pulled away
using wires never was torturous at all
so
i'm incredibly proud of this while there
were parts of thor and loki's
confrontation with malekith that were
filmed on location in iceland taking
advantage of some barren volcanic
landscapes the more effects heavy shots
were filmed on a green screen set this
behind the scenes footage really gives
you an appreciation for the amount of
faith actors have to put into their
directors and their special effects team
there's an art to the physicality of
performances with invisible elements
like cgi magic and tom pulls it off
beautifully while it may look silly on
set the final product was anything but
it can be surprising exactly which
elements of a scene are created using
cgi like loki's chains in the avengers
yeah for whatever reason those were cgi
not part of tom's costume like they were
for thor the dark world loki's
restraints and muzzle add a lot of
context to these shots so the behind the
scenes footage of the closing scene
looks pretty different without them
props to tom for being able to
convincingly move like someone in chains
even limiting how much he moved his
mouth and jaw
i think well there was always going to
be an unanswered question of what on
earth happened getting hulk smashed
became an odinson tradition in thor
ragnarok when thor faced off against
hulk in the arena loki clearly still
holding on to some baggage from his
fight with hulk is thrilled to see thor
get the same treatment of course tom
didn't actually have a spectacular fight
to react to you would never guess that
the only thing he's really looking at is
a room full of cameras and crew
in the first avengers movie thanos uses
one of his followers referred to as the
other to keep an eye on loki and monitor
his progress conquering earth the final
cut only kept one of their conversations
in with some horrific implications that
loki was being threatened with torture
but there were several more exchanges
between the two that got left out these
deleted scenes are unfinished but give
us an idea of what the raw filming
process looked like while the other
himself was achieved with practical
effects played by alexis denisof in
sculpts and makeup the alien world he
hangs out in when speaking to loki was
mostly blue screen
they followed me into
some interesting corners in the first
thor movie we meet the frost giants and
later learned that loki was originally
the son of their king not odin most of
the frost giants or yotens as they're
also called were filmed using practical
effects the actors would spend hours
having sculpts and makeup applied to
them to achieve just the right look but
this lengthy process wouldn't have been
practical for tom's brief scenes in
loki's yoton skin instead his red eyes
and blue skin were added in post as soon
as i look in the mirror after i've been
through it's like wow ever wonder why
loki's helmet has changed so many times
since the first thor movie even putting
on the helmet was more complicated than
you think since tom couldn't just pull
it on over his head the final product
used in thor actually had to come apart
in two pieces which would be snapped
together to encase tom's head according
to him it was like having his brain
cooked all of his body heat would build
up under the helmet driving him a bit
mad which he says he used to fuel his
performance that's probably why we see a
lot less of it in the avengers and it
didn't return until thor ragnarok with a
more minimalist redesign you have to be
careful what you let him
in because you can that can sort of
spill into what you're doing last but
not least is this deleted scene from
thor it's a fun character moment where
loki gets to cause some mischief after
being mocked and laughed at loki gets
even by turning a goblet of wine into
snakes the effects are unfinished and
there's even some shots where lighting
rigs are still visible
props to this extra who had to
convincingly react to a magical prank
that wasn't actually happening did you
know tom originally auditioned for the
role of thor they said his look wasn't
quite right for the role but when they
saw him they knew almost immediately
they needed him to play loki from the
massive popularity his character has
achieved it's easy to see they made the
right call